hello everyone and welcome back to the
match josé raúl capablanca vs. 1 course
though hope you're still enjoying your
excellent Saturday and funny story the
previous video in the host a row kappa
blanka series i mentioned there was a
game from the match the day i was game 9
but it was actually game 11 this is game
9 where Capablanca also plays d4 and for
some reason I thought that was game 9
but doesn't matter as I was planning to
show both of them that was a very nice
game this one has a bit of a different
character but still hopefully you're
gonna enjoy it
capablanca again has the white pieces
and opens again with the d4 but this
time we have f5 one course logos for the
Dutch defense and well there are
different approaches to how to play
against the Dutch defense capablanca
goes for the most direct 1.e4
immediately challenging the flank in a
similar fashion that you would challenge
a Sicilian with d4 Robert okay f
captures unfort nice to see three going
after d4 pawn nice to f6 defending the
pawn and now Bishop to g5 we have c6
preventing d5 also taking away some very
nice squares from the white knight and
here capablanca can recapture the pawn
back but he does have to give up the
bishop pair which he does Bishop
captures on f6 we have he captures on f6
and now comes Knight captures on e4
we have d5 kicking the knight back
Knight g3 and here one course was for
Queen to e7 check he has the black
pieces
he doesn't mind trading Queens and he
will look for some better chances with
the white pieces Queen to e2 we have
Queen captures on e2 Bishop captures on
e2 and now Bishop to b6 Corso prepares
the castle nice to f3
we have castles capablanca castles as
well and now comes Bishop to g4
h3 Bishop captures Bishop captures and
now bursts of capture some g3f captures
and g3 and now Knight to d7 course owner
wants to develop the ropes to the e-file
exchange both of the rooks and play this
endgame where a course will have a night
against the bishop but capablanca spawn
structure will be somewhat compromised
on the Kings side rook F 2 e 1 kappa
blanka takes a whole
of the open e file rook 88 challenging
the rook and now King to f1 we have F 5
course who doesn't want a cuppa blanket
to push G for rook captures an e8 rook
captures an e8 rook to e1 rook captures
anyone and King captures anyone and
night to have sex controlling the bishop
so now here you can see that basically
the first 19 moves of the game have been
just the trading going quickly into the
same game where both pairs have four
points on the Queen side it's a night
against the bishop and like we already
mentioned capablanca spawn structure on
the King side is somewhat compromised
and black has this excellent outpost for
the knight on e4 which does make black a
little bit better so let's see how young
kappa blanka copes with this kink the b2
of course you have to start to bring
your king into the game nice the e4
would check and here not going for
Bishop captures on e4 and F captures
which would give black this very strong
passed pawn but it instead after Knight
to e4 check a cup of Blanco goes for
King to e3 and now it's interesting this
Knight can capture the pawn on g3 but
then you allow came to f4 which attacks
the night and also attacks the f5 pawn
Corso is not interested in this
here he goes for Knight to d6 seems like
an odd move he wants to go for a night
c4 check and pick up the be to pawn but
perhaps g5 was a little bit better
simply not allowing taking control of
all of the important central squares not
allowing kappa blanka scheme to get
anywhere deeper into the position but
okay Knight to d6 going for Knight to c4
also perhaps testing young couple Blanca
will he perhaps
ruin his pawn structure on the Queen
side as well but of course Capablanca
goes Bishop to e2 controls the c-4
square with the bishop and now we have
king to f7 Corso also wants to bring his
King into the action King to a4 now you
can see that that g5 move would have
been a very nice idea as the king would
not be allowed to enter the f4 square
King to f6 preparing g5 but Capablanca
prevents that we have h4 and now if you
try h6 kappa blanka will just push h5
prevent it now GFI will be met with
each captures in g6 and Poisson King
captures and now King e5 white will in
enter blacks position and most likely
win this game
so after h4 we have g6 simply keeping
everything intact and now g4 cup of
lanka use this is extra G point to bust
open the position we have h6 and now you
don't want to capture on f5 if you
capture Knight captures then you will
not be able to defend both the h4 n the
d4 pawn so after h6 we have g5 with
Czech pawn captures H captures on g5 and
now King to e7 and here g4 by capablanca
if you start with King g5 immediately
yes you do grabs on space but black will
always be able to kick you back 9 f7
check you have to defend the pawn here
he can simply go back so not too much of
a move so instead g4 by Capablanca F
captures on g4 and now and in between
move Bishop to d3 yeah you could capture
immediately with either King or the
bishop but ok maybe with the King you
don't want to leave the defence of the C
4 square but here with Bishop to d3
threatening to capture the g6 bone and
create a passed pawn of his own couple
wanker forces one Corzo to think and
here is an excellent moment where 1/4
could have played a great move in 94 but
instead he played knife to a5 thinking
that it was just the same yes you are
blocking this g6 pawn but there is a
problem here
with Knight to e4 it's a bit better
because now if you play Bishop captures
you can go D captures and now after King
captures on e4 let's say King e6 King to
f4 going after the pawn you have to
eliminate the other pass pawn as well
g3 now King captures King to f5 you are
going after the g5 pawn after King f3
King captors in g5 King e4 and knocking
to f6 Corzo will have the outside passed
pawn and it will most likely end in a
draw
on the other hand after Knight to e4 if
you go King captors on g4 immediately
then you will face Knight F to check if
you were wondering about this King a4
Knight captures
III with check seek after Sundy three
and after King 2d6 you can see that
black is not perfectly fine the material
on the board is equal Capablanca spawn
structure in the center is again
compromised but he doesn't go 494
instead Corso goes for Knight to f5
whether he missed this or he saw that
both variations would lead to a draw and
Corso really wants to win the game he
goes Knight to f5 but he here he gives
Capablanca a bit more a room for for
some other ideas King captures on g4 and
still now capturing on d4 you will lose
the pawn on g6 but it's not much better
if you try to defend it you cannot use
the f6 square as the pond defends it if
you try keen to e6 to defend the night
then it's winning immediately simply
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
King to f4 and you will at some point
have to move your king and then white
will just capture this pawn because this
one controls the f6 square and this one
controls d5 square so at some point you
will have to make a move with your king
and then after King captures an f5 this
past G pond will be winning one such
example we might show is let's say a 5
is played b3 black will now try to play
as many moves as possible on the Queen
side just to prolong moving the King b6
a4 you can go c5 white will go c3 you
can go be captures either capture on
before but that would be much better for
white but still even if you push let's
say c4 you will play B captures on c4 d
captures on c4 and now black has used
all of his moves he has allowed the d5
with check now you will either capture
the pawn or move the King whatever you
do King captures here and now after you
leader push the point immediately oh
yeah you can push up on immediately and
just win the game straight out so this
is not possible
so one corso is forced to go for Knight
captures on d4 and ok Bishop captures on
g6
we have c5 now of course also wants to
create a pass bone of his own and now
King to h5 Capablanca wants to get his
King all the way to 8 7 move the bishop
somewhere and then start pushing
his passport 96 we have King to h6 and
now King to f8 controlling the g7 square
you're not if you allow the King to come
to h7 with her without being able to
bring the knight over here it will be of
course winning for a couple Blanca
Bishop to a5 attacking in the knight
Knight to g7 now and now Bishop to c8
attacking the pawn b6 and now we have g6
the 4 by horn Corazon and now b3
capablanca wants to push a 4 to lock all
the pawns on dark squares here we have
King to g8 and now comes a 4 and now you
can see that no pawn move can be made on
the Queen side as a couple Blanca three
points are controlling all of the four
pawns one quarter has on the Queen side
of course if black could start with a
six and then slowly make his way forward
it would be possible but the bishop is
controlling the a6 square so one Corso
is forced to repeat moves here we have
King to f8 and now comes Bishop back to
g4 Knights the e8
simple repeating moves King to h7 Knight
to g7 we have King back to h6 nights to
e8 and now capablanca saw that this way
he will not be making and be making any
progress but feel free to pause the
video here and try to find an idea for
white here how do you approach this
position so I will give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent endgame player and for
those who just won't enjoy it so well
you have to use your Bishop to
outmaneuver the king and the night so
here Bishop to e2 was played by
Capablanca Knight back to g7 now comes
Bishop to c4 at some point white will
decides to play Bishop to f7 to attack
the knight on e 8 we have 98 and now
first King to g5 now Capablanca will use
his King to get over to the center and
then black will not be able to keep an
eye on both the past Jeep on and on the
Queen side pawns as you'll see in the
game immediately going Bishop to f7 is
also possible after 97 King g5 kingi 7
we
reach a similar position where white
will still bring the king in the center
only through a different move order but
Capablanca goes ping g5 first king east
seven now we have if you try to go back
black goes back as well so King to f5
Knight to g7 check King e5 and now
Knight to h5 still controlling the g7
square Bishop to e2 attacking the knight
Knight goes back to g7 and now King to
d5 and here we have Knight the e8 if you
try King d7 to prevent the King from
entering the Queen side then comes the
Bishop b5 check and now you can decide
whether you want to go to c7 and then of
course King a five wins as you will get
a simply get your king to f7 and pulled
upon to victory or after king D 7 Bishop
Bishop e5 check King a 7 you will simply
play king c6 and then start picking up
all of the Queen side pawns
so after King d5 we have Knight to e8 by
Corso and now comes King to c6
Capablanca now enters the Queen side
Knight to g7 King b7 the point is under
attack and now King d6
King captures on a 7 grabs upon and now
King to c7 defending the pawns but it is
of a little matter a king to a6 wasting
a move and now we have nice the e8
Bishop to f3 Knight goes back to g7 and
now comes a bishop to the bishop to d5
preparing Bishop to f7 as if the knife
comes to e8 nice does come to you 8 as
black has to wait waste moves black
constantly has to keep an eye on the g7
square with the knight and the King
cannot move because all of the Queen
side phones will fall now that the base
of the pawn chain has been eliminated
Bishop to f7 attacking the Knights
defender of the g7 square Knight to g7
and now comes King to b5 again forcing
black to move Knight to f5 controlling
the g7 square from f5 but how do you
proceed now with white of course attack
again the base of the pawn chain
Capablanca pushes a5 and here black it's
pretty much the same whatever black
plays if you capture on a5 then you lose
you
your utter pawns so here nice the d6 was
played with check a couple Blanca move
the King King to a6 we have B captures
on a five and now capablanca simple to a
B g7 and it was in this position on move
59 that one course or resigned the game
there is no way to prevent the Jeep on
from queening you can capture but then
quite gets a queen in the game and it is
all over
sure that's the game we've already seen
that one game we haven't seen only the
Italian game work of Lanka avoided the
Queen the IDI amin's gambit but I have
put a link to that game in the
description below so you you could have
checked that out we've seen three other
games work up a Blanca wins and the one
of the games where he loses and with
this game we'll be finishing our match
against one course of the Cuban champion
and we're gonna get back to this some
more throughout the couple Blanca saga
but somewhere along the line capablanca
started his chess magazine called
Capablanca and juan korzel was his chief
editor in that magazine but yeah we're
gonna get back to that I do hope you
enjoyed this and it's very interesting
how first losing two games then
Capablanca really adapted and then
started winning it's not really he
always strived for the end game and for
for something that he really understands
and where he can simply use the
principles to play out through the game
and outplay his opponent and his
opponent of course always tried to use
some gambit some tricks something to use
the the opening theory that he knew so
well to outplay his young adversary but
yeah a wonderful victory we've already
seen game 11 which really was a was a
masterpiece but still here one course
will simply trade the down with the
black pieces entered a better end game
and he got outplayed by by the
thirteen-year-old Capablanca swam
there's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to once again thank Kurt
Mulder James Dobson
Dimitri Franz a young Roy and Robert
Silverman for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video so you're think all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with the Capablanca saga
thank you all and have an excellent rest
of the Saturday see you soon